many moons ago the wisest that the
JavaScript elders came down from the
mountain and said I have created jQuery
and the villagers said jQuery the actor
from zombeavers an elder Ezek for it was
he said no it is not a man it is magic
with these spells we shall tame the
capricious browser gods and bend them to
our will and the villagers rejoiced for
the browser gods were indeed capricious
and cruel and visited much misery upon
their lands and they reap loud they're
filled with the new magic and at the
time of the next code harvest all agreed
that the fruits of their labors tasted
sweet and ajaxy and there were
conferences and t-shirts and other
assorted merchandise and that was the
end of the first JavaScript era the tide
came and went the moon rose and fell
years passed the mile jquery was still
the dominant religion there were some
who grew fearful that it was not
powerful enough the elaborate designs of
the modern age then one day a traveler
came from the western lands of
zuckerberg ear and said hear me for i
bring a message of great import you're
all doing it wrong
these primitive incantations do not
befit our modern age of Science and
Technology
look at these wretched structures you
have built I would not step inside for
fear of my safety in Zuckerberg ear we
build not these mud huts but magnificent
towers that reach the very heavens and
we do it not with magic but with
machines come let me show you and the
villagers looked upon the machines and
they liked not what they saw the
traveller was cast out as a heretic and
yet some felt that these machines could
perhaps help them meet their own
ambitions and the heretics brew in
number until the heresy became the new
orthodoxy and the land was covered in
machines and that was the second era of
JavaScript I'm here today to talk about
the third area the chapter that's being
written right now my name is rich Harris
I am a graphics editor at the New York
Times and this talk is called computer
build me an app now when I talk about
the third era you probably think that
I'm going to talk about using the
platform in recent years it's become
very common to see web performance
advocates saying that we should use the
platform which is often interpreted as
don't use react and there's been this
rather contentious debate between the
two sides and the trouble is that both
kind of right there talking perhaps
teacher that it can simultaneously be
true the abusing frameworks leads to a
degraded user experience while also
being true that the Dom API is a hot
garbage so we have a problem and I
wanted to find a solution one of the
great things about living in New York is
that you get to attend Brooklyn Jay s
and the other borough Jay s meetups the
Jay s in Brooklyn Jay stands for Jet
Schmidt the co-founder of the meter and
he's a brilliant programmer and an
all-around good guy and one night at
Brooklyn jet Schmidt judge Schmidt was
explaining his vision of a
next-generation user interface framework
and he said something along these lines
the house rewrite directed graphs but
the runtime we have is a tree the Dom so
writing an app should just be writing a
graph and the compiler would figure out
whether dipoles are and rigged at the
Dom event code to make sure that to make
sure that that relationship stays
consistent across states now I don't
have a computer science background and
to be honest that was several beers in
at the time so this was just complete
gibberish it meant nothing to me but one
word did stick in my head
compiler and it led to an epiphany
frameworks are not tools for organizing
your code frameworks are tools for
organizing your mind they exist as code
and they often help you write better
code but their true value is in the way
they help you structure your thoughts
and express them so what if the
framework wasn't a thing that ran in the
browser at all what if it was a compiler
to understand the potential at this idea
we need to understand how frameworks
currently work before I go on there's
something that I need to make totally
clear I'm gonna be criticizing react in
this talk and I need you all to know
that it comes from a place of love react
is a wonderful tool it is part of a
pantheon of projects like jQuery
backbone d3 and others that haven't just
made life easier for the people who use
those tools that changed the way that
our entire community thinks about
solving these problems there is however
a tendency in our community towards
groupthink and an example of that is the
fairly widespread belief that react is
the end of web development that we've
reached the pinnacle and there is no
further progress to be made which is
what it looks like when you're at a
local maximum this talk is going to be
talking about exploring this new
unknown territory now the best thing
that reacted for the fronton community
was to popularize the idea of state
driven user interface and that's in
contrast to event-driven we used to
write code like this we would tell the
browser when something happens do
exactly these things in the state driven
world you instead say this is how I want
the user to see this is what I want the
user to see for a given state and you
tell answer the framework and the
framework communicates with the browser
on your behalf this is a very direct and
performant way of updating the Dom but
as many of you will know from personal
experience it just doesn't scale it
becomes too complex too quickly where is
this scaled beautifully the way that it
does that the dominant paradigm today is
the virtual Dom whenever your state
changes you rerender your entire
application and say here you are this is
what the user should now see the
framework then compares the virtual Dom
with the real DOM and figures out the
minimal set of operations that are
required to bring the Dom up-to-date now
you will often hear people say that the
virtual Dom is faster than the real DOM
which is obviously complete bollocks it
would be clearly much easier for the
browser if we go straight from the first
step to the last step virtual Dom is
pure overhead the reason that we
tolerate it is because of the
programming programming model that it
enables so we should ask ourselves could
we achieve that programming model
without all that indirection in the
middle if so your apps would get leaner
and they would get faster in other words
they would become spelt spelt is a real
word I didn't make it up the Cambridge
Dictionary describes it as attractively
thin graceful and stylish
merriam-webster has slender live sleek
urbane suave over there we have moving
and bending with these there's also a
definition from urbandictionary.com that
I quite like anything cool hip or
generally awesome although that was from
2005 so I have no idea if the kids are
still saying that nevertheless I will
take it
so how spelt works is you write your
component in an HTML file the compiler
turns it into a data structure called an
abstract syntax tree or AST and then it
generates some code this is some real
code that's spelt generated and that
gives you a normal JavaScript class
like any other that you can import into
your application you then give it an
element to render to and a tree of data
and it goes and does its thing we now
proceed to the live coding portion of
the talk so I'm just writing there with
me demo gods are not on my side
well this is a night I have a beach ball
on my screen
okay maybe yeah I don't think so
okay so we've replaced the hard-coded
data with a variable and if we open our
dev tools then we can manipulate that
data using the component API like so and
we can put any JavaScript expression in
these in these tags so and we can do
things like that a really nice thing
about using HTML is that you know what
I'm gonna try and just do it all on this
screen instead okay
so a really important thing to note here
is this CSS is being interpreted in the
context of the components markup and so
it's able to encapsulate it is added
this computer-generated class to the
element and it's doing the same thing to
the CSS class name down here and you'll
notice that because it's generating a
source map we're able to see exactly
where those Styles came from when you're
building a big complex app it is
incredibly useful to be able to know
where some CSS came from and that's
something that's often overlooked it's a
huge productivity win another thing that
we can do by analyzing the CSS in the
context that the mark-up is we can
detect and new styles sorry I've just
gotta get back to the same place oh my
god this is not one way and I'm gonna
skip ahead to the next slide we can add
event listeners in line on our elements
it might be I don't know
okay I think I might skip some of the
the next parts of this because it's
starting to get a little bit
embarrassing but we can and what I
wanted to show you is that we can start
to do some nice slick user interface
things like some really effective custom
transitions all we're doing here is
defining some CSS that's generated for a
given moment when your component is when
your element is being transitioned into
the Dom and normally with animations and
transitions that done inside a
requestanimationframe callback which is
less than ideal because that happens
inside the main thread and it's a often
a cause of jank spell takes that and it
turns into a CSS animation behind the
scenes which means that your animations
are more performant and they are kinder
on your phone's battery etc we can also
get transitions to talk to each other in
a sense this is an application where we
have some to do's that have not been
done up here and down here some to do's
that have been done and if I click on
one of these labels it'll move it from
one side to the other which is fine but
the human brain doesn't really like that
it doesn't like it when objects
disappear and suddenly reappear it
prefers it when objects maintain some
sort of sense of constancy and so we're
generating some helper transitions down
here with this function called crossfade
and if I add those to my component
I this was fine an hour ago tell you
what I will tweet how the slides as they
are supposed to appear let's move on and
so an important shift has happened here
in a very real sense you're not writing
the code behind your app you are writing
some instructions and the browser that
sorry the compiler is generating the
code for you
and this is this is an important shift
because a lot of code is plumbing and no
disrespect to plumbers but I want to be
able to operate at a more creative level
I want to be more like an architect than
a plumber so I like to focus on the
difficult creative decisions and leave
the boring grunt work to my assistant
the compiler now a question that I get
all the time is why not use JSX and I'm
gonna get answered again at this
conference if I don't answer here so
spelt uses a language called HTML X
which is a superset of HTML in contrast
the JSX which is a superset of
JavaScript and the reason for that is
that this is a nightmare for a compiler
in HTML X this is always going to be a
text mode which means that you can
compile code accordingly but in JSX it
could be an element the component text
it could be an array of fragments
containing all three and the compiler
can't do anything with that it needs to
know what the value of that expression
is going to be which is why we need all
of the virtual Dom machinery now having
said that the Facebook team are working
hard on this problem and just yesterday
Dominic Ganaway and successfully
completed a little experiment to get
react server-side rendering in a similar
compiled format and react SSR is now as
fast as spell and even though
client-side is a much much harder
problem this is something that you
should be very excited about if you're a
react user nevertheless I prefer to use
HTML based languages when I'm describing
user interfaces because hTML is the
language of the web it means I don't
need to worry about all these oddities
that JSX presents and I also feel that
using an HTML based language is more
inclusive to the very large numbers of
developers who are simply more
proficient with HTML and CSS than they
are with JavaScript now I'm not the only
person whose reach the conclusion that
compilers should be the next frameworks
stencil is a project inspired by spelt
which leans in on web components glimmer
is the Ember rendering engine
it does something interesting it
complies your components to a very
efficient bytecode format Marco is a
framework from eBay which delivers
really good performance with some
compiler techniques and angular is
working on a next-generation renderer
called IV these are all fantastic
frameworks and you should check them out
a question that I get very often is
surely if your components are being
converted into vanilla JavaScript it's
going to be bulkier than if there were
just the instructions to a framework and
so eventually you're going to reach an
inflection point where you would have
got a smaller app by just using a
regular framework in the first place
where that inflection point 6 is going
to differ from frameworks a framework
but the theory you know holds true but
there are some important things to know
first of all cell components actually
have a very low incremental cost because
the compiler is able to reuse a lot of
code but secondly in practice by the
time you get to that point you should be
using code splitting anyway and with
code splitting you just don't reach that
inflection point the thing about codes
listing which is a technique that allows
the browser to lazily load assets as
when when they're needed is that if
you're using a traditional framework
your smallest chunk is at least as large
as the framework and the other
dependencies that you're using and Spell
just simply doesn't have that problem as
it happens we can solve this problem
empirically conduit is an application
that there's part of the real-world
project which is an endeavor to get
different frameworks to build the same
app to see how they compare at a real
use case it's basically a medium clone
and according to a recent article by
yacht's X Shea it does scale and spell
is down here in the middle next to Akron
and those o2 they're the three sort of
top performers this is the initial
payload size and this is the reference
react implementation which is much much
larger it's not entirely fair because
this one isn't using code splitting and
the spelt one is but even if you add up
all of the JavaScript assets for that
app the salt version is still about 40%
the size of the react one so yes it
definitely does scale
we can see the effect of that in the
startup metrics the reaction starts
after about three seconds this is time
to first meaningful paint and the spelt
version comes in at about a second and a
half there's another important metric
which is lines of code spell has about
half the number of lines of code that
the react person does and that's not an
aberration that's something that we see
all the time because it turns out that
you can express UI concepts much more
cleanly and succinctly if you're using a
language that is designed for that task
fewer lines of code is good because it
means you can write your apps quicker
but it also means that your apps more
maintainable there will be fewer bugs
spell is reasonably flexible and
powerful but you need something more if
you're going to build ambitious apps and
in the react world we have this
fantastic project called next the idea
behind next is each page of your app is
a component and when you first visit the
app you get the server rendered version
and then from there on you get the
client rendered version so the
navigation feels instantaneous and
native and so I started thinking what
could we take the same spelt philosophy
of compilers and static analysis and
apply it to that problem and yes we can
Ramez my own so I'm going to create a
new separate project sakura's short for
spelt an app maker actually you know
what I'm gonna go to the here's one I
made earlier so then we don't need to
wait for dependencies to install and if
I build my app then this is this is the
basic starter template and you can see
as before we've got the client side
rendering which is nice and slick it's
very fast but if we look at the the
actual market that you get from the
server it's it's server render which
means that you get that very fast
initial initial load if I were to build
this
then we can have a look at the the
production stats for this
and you can see that it's less than
seven kilobytes
remember you can't see it's quite small
but it's less than seven kilobytes of
JavaScript which is still like more than
is necessary but it's a pretty good
start for reference if we look at the
the same app bill using next then it's
well over 200 kilobytes which is frankly
too much for an app that doesn't yet do
a great deal and I have some numbers on
the server-side rendering performance so
I don't want to get too hung up on the
performance stuff I want to I want to
promote the idea that we should be
comparing frameworks along other more
interesting dimensions such as those
this framework helped me build a more
accessible web I haven't shown you this
but spelt and will warn you if you build
if you use things that aren't accessible
does it help us build slick user
interfaces does it help us write fewer
lines of code and can we write tools
that are more sophisticated than stuff
that's based on the command line I've
been very inspired by these two projects
so in my remaining 60 seconds I am going
to try and show you what I've been
working on and this is a a graphical
user interface for building sapper amps
and you can do some pretty cool stuff if
you have tools that are deeply
integrated with the frameworks that they
serve
I can open an editor and I can go
straight to the page that I'm currently
on if I want to look at a particular
element and edit that then I can click
the the crosshairs button and it'll take
me straight to the source code so I can
go ahead and edit it which is a huge
productivity room I've been building
apps like this for short while and it is
transformed and how quickly I'm able
able to build stuff and so in summary if
the first era was the agrarian age in
which homesteaders tended to their code
bases by hand and the second era was the
Industrial Age when we started to use
machines for everything and people
worried a little bit about the pollution
but we can't deny that it had this
transformative effect on productivity
the
the third age is the information age the
machines are becoming intelligent and
this is the point at which we can stop
and say how can computers help us
fulfill our potential as creative
professionals I think this is some very
largely unexplored territory it doesn't
just apply to user interface it also
applies to tools and everything else
that we work on and so I hope that you
will come and explore it with me and
with that thank you